so we're told that g of x is equal to x
squared plus five x minus three and h of
y is equal to three times y minus one
squared minus five
and then we're asked what is
h of g of negative six and this the way
it's written might look a little strange
to you
this
this little circle that we have in
between the h
and the g that's our function
composition symbol so function
composition
symbol and one way to rewrite this it
might make a little bit more sense so
this h of g of negative 6
you could rewrite this as
this is going to be the same thing as
g of negative 6
and then h of that
so h of g of negative 6. notice i spoke
this out the same way that i said this
this is h of g of negative 6. this is h
of g of negative 6. i find the second
notation far more intuitive but it's
good to become familiar with this
function composition notation this
little circle because you might see that
sometime and you shouldn't stress it's
just the same thing as what we have
right over here now what is h of g of
negative 6 and we just have to remind
ourselves that this means that we're
going to take the number negative 6
we're going to input it into our
function g
and then that will output g of negative
6 whatever that number is we'll figure
it out in a second and then we're going
to input that into our function h
we're going to input that into our
function h and then what we output is
going to be h of
g of negative 6 which is what we want to
figure out g
h of
g of
negative six
so we just have to do it one step at a
time a lot of times when you first start
looking at these function composition it
seems really convoluted and confusing
but you just have to i want you to take
a breath and take it one step at a time
well let's figure out figure out what g
of negative 6 is it's going to evaluate
to a number in this case and then we
input that number into the function h
and then we'll figure out another that
going to map to another number
so g of negative 6 let's figure that out
g of negative 6
is equal to negative 6
squared
plus 5 times negative 6
minus 3
which is equal to positive 36
minus 30 minus 3. so that's equal to
what 36 minus 33 which is equal to 3.
so g of negative 6 is equal to 3.
g of negative 6 is equal to 3. g of
negative 6 is equal to 3. you input
negative 6 into g it outputs 3. and so h
of g of negative 6 has now simplified to
just h of 3 because g of negative 6 is
3.
so let's figure out what h of 3 is
h
of three notice whatever we output it
from g we're inputting that now into h
so that's the number three so h of three
is going to be three
times three minus one
three minus 1 squared minus 5 which is
equal to 3 times
2 squared this is 2 right over here
minus 5 which is equal to 3 times 4
minus 5
which is equal to
12 minus 5
which is equal to 7
and we're done
so you input negative 6 into g
you get 3 and then you take that output
from g and you put it into h and you get
7. so this right over here is 7. all of
this has come out to be equal to 7. so h
of g of negative 6 is equal to 7. h of
g of negative 6
is equal to 7. input negative 6 into g
take that output and input it into h and
you're going to get 7.